greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by Vince arrow watches let me
explain them to you I love my miss arrow
watch I got a beautiful silver white
combination with the silver band on they
sent me a rose gold one
I think Lee's got the black black piece
listened and Sara watches a very cool a
wristwatch is a personal statement okay
you elevate your game Vince arrows
handcrafted luxury watches and an
unbeatable price
Vince arrow provides bold timepieces
always putting quality above all else
listen get your visera watch today right
now with the special offer for the
church family go to Vince arrow watches
comm and enter my code Church CH you are
CH at checkout for 15% off your order
and worldwide shipping is always free
that's when Sara watches comm promo code
Church Vince arrow grab a pen VI n CEO
watches dot-com promo code Church and
you get 15% off and free shipping
worldwide trust me when you see these
Vince arrow watches you're gonna go oh
my god the church is also brought to you
by and I'm welcoming them to the church
policy genius listen part of adulthoods
is having to do things that you really
don't want to do like red-eye flights
working late visiting in-laws and
getting life insurance alright
a policy genius they just don't make
life insurance easy they can also help
you find the right home auto and
disability insurance I went on to look
at car insurance I got a quote and I
gotta tell you this was the fastest I've
ever gotten a quote in my life I gave
them a little information about me and a
few clicks later boom I was comparing
great rates so if you need life
insurance but you don't know you don't
want to deal with all the legwork
there's that's a problem head to policy
genius.com that's policy genius.com
it's the easy way to compare all the top
insurers and find the best value for you
all right policy genius delegate what
you hate is
especially if you hate getting life
insurance li take this [ __ ] meal
Brendan Schaub in the [ __ ]
what's up brother what's up my man
love you man love you - you look great
what's going on how's the baby
baby's good you have another one coming
in November how old is your son now
three and a half three and a half that's
fun it's fun he's a critter though
daycare uh he's in like a summer camp
right now he's in like grade preschool
good but he likes to hang out with other
kids
here's my more break potty training now
though it took the yeast man become
filthy its tremendous yeast it's great
on their own it's great it's amazing
when you see the evolution are they pick
up [ __ ] on their own then one day
they'll tell you daddy you don't need to
go in the bathroom the mall on my
privacy
press your heart just breaks like daddy
get the [ __ ] out
he's also yeah he's either gonna be just
a badass athlete or serial killer cuz he
does certain [ __ ] like you when you're
potty trained you gotta get rid of
everything I make him realize like when
he takes a [ __ ] alright you keep doing
that man we're gonna take your [ __ ] away
so we've been taking toys been taking
his iPad taking all the stuff that the
last straw is he has this like we called
a Yaya it's like a pacifier set since
he's one day old and he only gets in
renowned them but it's his that's his
ride or die it's a line he's obsessed
with it and that my girl goes my girls
but not Mexican Nazi [ __ ] she runs a
tight ship I don't agree with all that
she runs a tight [ __ ] ship she was if
if he shits pants again I'm gonna take
that yaaaa and I'm I throw it in the
trash in front of him I went oh it's
gonna be a world war do you think that
that's his [ __ ] yeah and so he should
just pay italic now a damn dude you
messed up and I go my girl smells it's
just that's it alright target that's it
she opens up the trash can grabs his
pacifier goes like this and it comes
over and I seem like looking she drops
in the trash from went out there goes my
night it's gonna be World War [ __ ]
three he just looks at both of us and
goes I have others dang gangster I just
turn around cuz I was laughing hop tough
is she oh oh well vanish woman the only
reason why I picked the daycare we went
to like six daycares and they were all
nice as [ __ ] some of them had goat
cheese
welcome to soybeans yeah yeah tofu I
walked into one I saw two Spanish women
I looked at my wife oh this is what I'm
like this is it
and these two Spanish women all playing
I try to explain to my wife but the
Spanish culture your girls what
ethnicity she's why this could be I
didn't see your girl was no no I don't
know why like my white girls nice pale
with dirty feet Venice yeah I don't like
to hide why you know I love I love all
women yeah pretty but I always like the
Irish world all right I was a kid but
the other day we went to a party about a
month and a half ago we gotta calm oh my
daughter goes look it's Carlos a friend
of the school and Carlos his mom was
there was a little baby
and Carlos just happened to walk into
the street say hello to mercy there was
no cars coming after this she goes God
looks bad out there
Carlos kept walking I fell out that
means wait and this [ __ ] said uno dos
and that kitchen has a thought and the
kid three is it
I mean her as my wife looked at me and
she was like holy SH a go I told you Oh
Bravo vanished mom's give you what they
got a short fuse and then she starts
flying oh dude he gives me chills up my
spine when my when my kid mess up and
I'm like I just like I'm going dude your
mom you know no ma'am I would and she
speaks Spanish when she starts slang
Spanish he understands Spanish better
than English
yeah I don't know what the [ __ ] they're
saying good all I know is he screwed
when she starts slinging that Spanish
and he understands that he gets tears in
his eyes I'm like dude you know he
[ __ ] up right yeah I'm not going on a
lot of Spanish because she won't want to
talk it now but as she gets older
oh she's near his friend now she knows
what I'm talking about no heat my son
understands Spanish better than English
he speaks both he's fluent but he
definitely understands Spanish better
and then like his nanny only speak
Spanish to him his grandma who watches
only speaks Spanish he only gets his
English from me TV and then when he goes
to school but he understands it all man
you know what being a dad
nothing better brother nothing nothing
better when you do that last show
explain to people when you do that last
show on Saturday night
call and they put the check in your hand
that or you give a [ __ ] about by people
calling you let's go for a drink
there's a woman giving out [ __ ] and
then you're like that's all fine and
dandy but all I can think about is get
on that plane daddy get home my kid oh
man get the [ __ ] home to the yeah and
I'm sorry I know you've made plans I I'm
not kind of McGregor I'm not showing up
to the VIP yeah yeah I don't hang out
soon as they get that check the weekend
is over all I'm thinking about it's
coming home to my [ __ ] child and are
you old school joy like I some some
comics will have you know the check
wired to CAA or their agency and then
they get the percentage I need the
physical check like I'm from 1983 all my
money give me I want the physical jekima
cuz when you wire it I don't feel like I
get I want mama I need as soon as I get
offstage I need the man to hand me that
you're like Maurice I want my money I
want my money
when you shoot a movie this is something
for young comics and actors to know you
get to LA you're hungry you're starving
an agent signed you you go to a
commercial agent they sign you and while
you're signing you don't realize you
sign a piece of paper that says that all
their checks go to the company first yes
you get a check in the mail well by law
theater and television movie and film is
ten days ten days you should have your
check if you're a Screen Actors Guild
performer if you're a Screen Actors
Guild commercial actor commercial checks
of 30 days okay but in reality let me
tell you what happens they get to check
four days later on except the commercial
company sticks the money in the bank and
they save it for two cuts later then
they marry you to check and you got the
five-day travel they'll make it thirty
two days but they have your money so
what I do is when I do a movie TV
anything I rip that paper up and I give
it to the people and they look at me and
go but if this has to be this way no I
get the money did I pay the Commission
and because they come they work for you
there's a lot of young comics and
Aster's don't notice CAA works for
whoever W me they work for you so the
check comes in me and then I'll pay them
the Commission percent up the gate I
don't know I'll sit no give me my
[ __ ] tie and I have to have it not
very I'm very like I love like when
people contact me now again and you know
a lot of people don't listen to listen
or Joey's a dick no I'm not a nice I'm
gonna tell you this story somebody calls
you and says hey I got a gig for you
pays five hundred and you take that gig
and also you get home and your check
bounces you got to go through a process
when you have an agency you just call
the agent I'm going to check bounced
go do your job and hang up the phone and
that agency will soon that agency will
[ __ ] on of them they won't go to Paul
Allen Allen so now people call me no way
man I got this gig for you is this not
go you're gonna call CAA and they're
like in shock they're like well can't we
do it off the books I know nothing
nothing with me is off the books
everything runs through CA some guy
approached me a month ago I have a movie
for you I can give you this a mommy will
go through CAA because I really didn't
want to go through an agent then I go
you're really not real no you're not
real you know you know CIA's not gonna
play no [ __ ] up there not any coloring
book Daniel half the [ __ ] and
innovative I rather them go through them
it's like if I listen in my world I'll
give you ten thousand dollars you want
to pick up a kilo if you get mugged on
the way that Brendon as much as I love
you that's on you we got to set up a
payment plan right now that's my 10 G's
well you got beat up you broke your arm
next time bring new chucks I don't know
what the [ __ ] to tell you yeah but
that's my 10 G's which which I found out
I'm a I'm sure I can tell us - I'm a
good buddy who's in the dark side of
business and he got pinched and he was
telling me I go you were talking about
it and he goes I'm in for let's say a
million he was I'm in for I got pinched
in for a million I go I'm not that big
of deal you know No
so the government takes that right I
have to pay them a million but that
stuff that I was responsible for that
means I can make 2 million because I
give that I got it I need to get that
money back to these guys who I was
pushing the ship for so it's gonna cost
me 2 million so I come up with something
to get 2 mil
as a dam you live a crazy life my mom so
that's why you stress yeah yeah you're
responsible you know why Brendon
because when I was really hungry I don't
know how many times I came home and put
a check in the bank went to [ __ ] get
a sandwich and the check bounced
I can't tell you as a matter of fact to
be honest yeah it got to the point where
I would tell people cash
there's a [ __ ] famous story and we're
best friends now
Joe Milosh is Gabriel's manager we're
best friends I love Joe Milan Gabriel is
very one of the best guys in the
business and Joe used to booked
Bakersfield theaters and stuff and one
night you know it was Valentine's Day
Joe calls me at 5:00 and he goes I got
this gig somebody cancelled it's 500
bucks
look 500 bucks in those days to me was
how long ago is this joy this is 2001
there's my me and my girls first
Valentine so the deal was I said come on
the fall in at five I go I'm gonna take
the gig but when I get up there it's
five Benjamin Franklin's yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I get up there I do
this show this [ __ ] gives me a
check and I threw it back Adam and this
is when I was knee-deep of the geebo
coke a day I already called the drug
dealer and called the mother's comin all
the way down with the balance of his
check with the put the 500 cash he went
to give me a check on I threw it out
yeah attacked them I'd hand they had all
separate us and the headliner goes
forget it I'll give you the five out of
my father's the headliner gave me the
five and he kept the check and for a
long time there was a running story and
now we're best friends College I
apologize I had it but that's how
serious I was I was to the point where
listen why are you giving me a check
have you ever had any gigs where they
just didn't pay you Joey when you're
coming up obviously not now good luck
with that now um I had gigs where people
try to run game Brendan I'm gonna give
you five others to do this theater and a
plane ticket and then the theater is
three quarters back and
when you get to hotel you at the gate
I'll call you the hotel room I'll pay
you then on Sunday
I have holiday your door knocks and they
open up the door and pretty soon they're
telling you man I gotta tell you what
happened the radio money they wanted all
their money up front so I'm not told you
file I'm gonna give you full but I'll
catch on the next one that was happening
a lot like and that was tough to explain
if it's tough to live with but I had no
pit that 400 bucks yeah yeah and then
what happens is there's a day that you
go no I'm not taking those no more and
you have to stick to your word even if
you starving on things if you're hungry
I had a situation eight years ago right
before I mentally right before this
whole thing started I was doing
something I was doing a podcast for
Felicia and I started getting a little
bit of heat I was selling 100 tickets a
show and I got a call from the guy one
man he goes hey I'll give you 200 bucks
to come up and do this show when I get
up there he was charging 25 and I was
the guy for the longest shot
oh hell and the VIP greeting me you know
and I'm like and I did it and on the way
home I go this type of equipment yeah so
he called me three months later he's
like let's do it again we did great I go
yeah you did great now the Gulf now the
dough is 80% of the door this is before
an agent anybody I was in no position to
ask for 80 percent of the door like it's
80 percent of the door I think goes all
right I gotta get back here and I talk
to my partners so I talked to a friend
of mine Rick Ramos and Rick Ramos goes
would you tell that kid he says you get
a little bit too big for your britches
and I didn't say nothin to the kid well
once this revolution started I saw him
at the store about three years ago and I
one left I'm like a manly way I'm seeing
you know why don't you have five minutes
I know you remember what I did that gig
for you for the small 200 yeah yeah I
don't remember one night you call me the
next time and you said 80% of the dough
and you said I was getting too big for
my britches I don't know I wasn't gonna
break
my britches but this was the result yeah
that's what I was because I started
turning down shitty games because
waiting yeah you know in 2007 there was
a strike in this town I used to work on
a movie once a month or a TV show people
just call you hey we've known the mall
Brendan I got a scene
it's a jailer it's you and [ __ ] Tony
Soprano - two minutes I'll give you 800
I would do all those but then when the
strike came I started getting YouTube
movies is that the writer strike you do
ya wish writers make the world go round
by the way yeah there's nothing without
them yes the writers strike some when
they came back a lot of work went away
to different other countries like Canada
started shooting and you know Virginia
so got away from here so every movie I
shot two thousand eight to ten was $100
a day movie that means you got to bring
your own clothes since it's $100 a day
that you're a strip club owner they're
like I'll let you shoot it in the
daytime so you got to go in there with
that clothes at 2:00 in the morning now
you're up all night for what and you're
just doing that to pay the bills that's
thought at the time I was doing that's
how supplement you got seven forms
income you you know you got standing up
I had my stand-up and opening up for
Rogan and I had film and TV that was my
stream of income so I would get my
homework I would open up the Rogan from
time to time and then I was doing movies
and one day I go I went right over here
sort of no Hope Diamond guy took me out
I want to do this with you and do this
with you and it's a series of mini
series and I call offices in this day he
told me all these bums and losses that
were in it the guy that was next to me
was only in it because his
brother-in-law was putting up the money
that type of [ __ ] and I went home and I
made a constant choice and I said uh I'm
not doing those no you down with her a
year I kept getting calls and there were
like five hundred three hundred thousand
and I was going I'm not doing it and
finally one day I got a call to do the
Stowe home De Niro movie and I go this
is what happens when you stick to your
guns yep you have to stick to your guns
yeah knows a powerful word just so the
listeners know to whenever they
especially with tort he's been the
business so long I Joey gives me more
advice on
boring and where to go where to say no
than anyone I know why not because
you're great i watch i've been i sat
here and I watched twenty thousand
careers go down the to and for all
different various of reasons some
careers go down because the drugs I saw
a lot of careers down go down because of
wrong management and I saw a lot of
careers go down because of the hustle
the shuffle is Lisa act it's got a great
twenty minutes he goes to the improv one
night a certain agency and management
Sam they got a Montreal showcase Lisa
hat goes to Montreal they give him a
half million dollar deal he's gonna do a
show he's and don't call me three years
what show is he gonna give you yeah only
come from a Jewish house my mother smack
me when I was four
you know the show don't go we get
250,000 after taxes and his commissions
the chain of [ __ ] but now I send them
out for four things he don't book him
and guess what he's selling tickets yep
so then he go to the bottom of the poly
agency now it's Lee's decision on what
he's gonna do does he pack up and leave
or does he push through and do stand-up
and forget about the TV show yeah you
know there's dad those people for a
while that were just putting you through
a tomato grinder and these people out
all those them half million dollar deals
lot of them a God now they were gonna be
stars because they got pushed through a
thing my Hut most respect for Joe Rogan
is in his podcast isn't his MMA skills
is none of that [ __ ] when I got here in
98 and 97 and 8 98 and 99 Joe was on a
show called I learned a lot from the Joe
broke and he was on the show called News
Radio future by the table read on
Tuesday blocking on Wednesday blocking
on Thursday they shot on Friday the
shoot started at 6 o'clock at night Joe
Rogan's name would be on the list every
one of those nights he would go from NBC
straight to the [ __ ] studio there was
nights that you know this to shoot a TV
show and then have to go do a 15 dollar
spot nightmare so when I saw that I
learned a lot from Joe that a lot of
people didn't learn
no matter you're in a TV show you still
gotta flex that muscle because those
people that started with you solely
Brendan at least out of the month
apartment with goombas and we move here
together and we're doing everything
together we got a house together your
your regular at The Improv leaves at the
Laugh Factory I'm at The Comedy Store we
get to deal TV show for a year he looks
down at us
you're stiffs is still doing stand-up
you know oh listen at the end of the
year least TV goes show gets guess what
we're like Charlie we're in the bush
yeah
we're in the bush like Charlie yep
you're out [ __ ] around more when my
pocalypse no huh he goes Charlie's in
the bush you were too busy going to the
will turns to hang out with Mike yeah
this guy you know you didn't do stand-up
so now your TV show gets canceled and
those two roommates are yours I [ __ ]
had a fatty
I had ahead of you but that's the thing
a lot of comics too not this day and age
but back especially from a while ago a
lot of them we're doing stand-up to get
movies in TV right now it's really not
that way is it like no matter what let's
say now that you would let's say you
said something ridiculous on here or on
an interview on TV you don't press you
say something outlandish they can't take
stand up boy friend okay can't take this
podcast wait they can't take nothing
there's nothing and do nothing they can
do you know iTunes could bang your
YouTube could ban you for whether it's a
will there's a way for you to get your
message out or your voice out stand up
you never stop stand up is your three
times a week four five six seven because
you only gonna get better and better sir
how many gets better you're writing gets
better sir you know the people that
don't sell tickets today you know Dave
Attell is funny that he's ever been
now it's one of the greats if he was
funny 20 years ago can you imagine what
he's doing now yeah louis c.k those guys
were when I was a feature act those guys
were already headline well thing about
Bill burr
they took him a while burned the Philly
bit comes out don't they it wasn't big
before that but that Philly bit comes
out and then just but it's a tie it's
time yes
yeah stand-up is like MMA you know you
know I know you shot a special yes sir
and I know you got a lot of [ __ ] from a
lot of people you know you made me laugh
with the special I was very proud of you
thank you sir I mean three years
yes insult you sir like I told somebody
I go I'm 56 years old what if tomorrow
the UFC called me and said Joe we want
you to fight dennis siver because nobody
knows how old Dennis eBrush I mean he's
not around anymore but he was a janitor
at Auschwitz yeah that's done zone
indeed Ron spincake that hauling cloth
they made him he was old enough to sweep
the joint like Hitler was dead already
but you can tell like you've been
constructing a nosh wits you know you
ever talk to him we think the tech
titties he's a Nazi [ __ ] you ever see
what he controlled rambling like the
German not steam sure yeah no [ __ ]
something crazy on the document it he's
a great guy he's a Nazi we don't know
that is a great spinning yeah but he
spins kicking leaves the hill I had that
did you ever see like some people used
it when you do it when you do a leg kick
to throw that spinning ball around and
powerful not have a birth certificate
it's just give you the SWAT stick with
the SSR yeah yeah or something like that
I'd say right now we don't we don't know
how old better Seaver is ah just drop
down to 265 we're gonna let you fire
them he'll fight you let me wait but you
gotta be 265 you can't be bigger than
Roy Nelson you gotta fight at 265 yeah
and you have six months to Train
yeah no smokers no I ask how you know
you were thrown into the weeds of debt
my friend
all right that's my a great I love gotta
body then yeah picked you up one day and
they said you're gonna overlap MC and
feature and just start it like uh it
well I can see how you think that joy
but it was a little different than that
because remember I was on the road with
talent for four years okay so so when
most guys doing open mics I was doing
15-20 minutes I mean you're talking for
four years with Bryan Callen opened up
doing our live fighting the kids how are
you feeling that onstage I mean it's uh
you know it's a you're new but but that
was in front you know my first stand-up
ever my open mic was in Brea Ontario
sorry Ontario 600 people sold out so
that was my first open mic people yeah
that's your crowd
it's my crowd but 600 people expecting a
show so yeah crowd for like two minutes
it's my crowd with yeah first like oh
they're shop from the podcast we know
how it is that's [ __ ] pivot after
three minutes
yeah that's guy from you know entourage
yeah no but they're there to laugh so
after two three minutes you get do your
[ __ ] so I was thrown in this training
camp you know I'm saying this so my open
mics were touring touring with Callan
Sigma and there's wing torn torn torn
torn torn and then I do a live fine kid
The Comedy Store and then they go man we
love you do a set in the belly room and
then it just starts going from there
then I'm doing you know [ __ ] spots in
the belly room and laugh factor I'm
doing Armenian night stuff like that and
then I think three like two years into
that and then you're on medium now but
they thought I was I think that's why
they invited oh you were training over
there with Abu Dhabi and [ __ ] the
head movement with uh yeah yeah what's
Rhonda's Dvorkin where the [ __ ] it is
but then and then driving over by the
way don't make sense pick me up Shepherd
did you know I yep sorry doing that and
then re show on this is not happening
I mean they had auditions or something
at the Comedy Store and Justin with I
was there I was there yeah yeah yeah
thank you
yeah yeah I remember you
and then I did that and then they went
I've met economy central whoever's
running it because I was already out
people think I was a go shop be on the
show that's not how it went they had
those auditions it happened that one and
then you you liked it I Mara already
asked you to host right right
and then then what we liked it but it's
just missing something so I kept work
out work out then they had another
audition for it did it then again we
like you I like it it's missing
something and I'm trying to figure it
out and Bert Kreischer I'm forever in
debt to Bert Kreischer I [ __ ] love
that game with all my heart
Bert has me on his podcasts and then
some he said oh it's almost own about
the story you did on this is not
happening
tell it to me just tell it to me don't
just tell to me how you're doing I tell
him and then he's like man you ever
thought about this or what if you put
this here we've put this here and that's
really I didn't think of it like that is
think I want you don't think it was a
bit thing it was a story that was a
story yeah and then so took the notes
from burp my back in the drawing board
Tommy store Laugh Factory improv bombing
right people know who I am they're
bombing bombing then I get that final
this is not happening they'll there you
go and then I got that then I got that
and then just kept kept kept on keeping
on there but all that all that stems is
the the Showtime special everything stem
though the rock is that is that bit that
I done this not happening so I toured
with that for whatever three and a half
you know four years how is the walk
through the walk down the path to
fighting compared to sitting in the back
waiting for your name to be called
is there any comparisons to that feeling
now are you going to get play on face
now people people think there's commune
talking [ __ ] apples avocados man I
mean in the back I could train as hard
as I want I grabbed on all my [ __ ]
tease I'm sorry dot my eyes cross my T's
I'm ready to go but the guys I'm
fighting are world-class men those
[ __ ] are pretty good so matter
how good I am that guy might be better
that night and I'm [ __ ] terrified
even though I'm in the best shape of my
life I'm ready to go we got the game
plan I do some things better than him
[ __ ] happens in comedy I mean you gotta
try new [ __ ] you're gonna
some nights but in comedy if you do it
long enough you keep going keep going
you're working on your right you can
come up with 15 minutes that in general
you know that you get you pull that ace
out of your [ __ ] back pocket with any
crowd it's gonna be pretty funny in
fighting there's no that I'm not pulling
that went off on the bagel shop yes
right now they will have to fight people
like it was amazing tell the viewers for
sure if you contacted me and offered me
a million dollars to fight that [ __ ]
I'd have to pay somebody 200 grand to
push me now like don't know there I
don't know how people do that I that
walk to the Octagon most all most
terrifying thing joy in the world and
that camera in front of me I would not
picture this jungle [ __ ] out like get
that camera up Junior picture this so uh
you're warming up in the back and I was
fortunate where I was fought I guess
fortunate but I always had to wait so
let's say it's a 7:00 p.m. pay-per-view
all my fights were pay-per-view at least
main slots
I never went early so I had to sit in
the back in my [ __ ] jog while you see
guy come in after and then and then you
see him before going this is my moment
to go get knocked the [ __ ] out come back
to locker room and you're like oh and so
you're waiting and then your coach
should go alright you're six fights away
let's start warming up and then you
start warming up they wrap your hands
that's we knew it's real and then what I
would do I'd always look at the at the
lineup and it the two fights before me
if there were smaller weight classes I'd
know typically it's can go to decision
so I get some time I got thirty minutes
five minutes between each fight so I got
about 45 minutes to warm up on be good
if it's heavyweights middleweights or
light heavyweights better have your [ __ ]
ready because it's something it knocked
out pretty fast so you don't you have no
idea what's gonna happen
why so I'd always okay I better start
warming up a little harder a little
harder and they're just pacing back and
forth and then you know there's like
whatever I'm what I do and got what am i
doing this is awful this awful and then
fire the whole shop you're up and
there's your walk-in and suicide and
then it because it's his team there
there's a huge black curtain you're
walking through the rain it's so it's so
lonely it's so [ __ ] cold man and
there's a black curtain and usually
their team would be in front of me
there and they're all talking teas
nervous pacing back and forth and you're
just there like here we go man there we
go and then he walks out his song plays
you hear talking [ __ ] about knocking you
out and then the black curtain closes
and the cameras in your face and then
your walk out music kids and then you
start walking hit that crowd I would
have a heart attack like I would I would
probably will have my blood pressures up
right now thought yeah when I looked at
the lineup when I saw my name I would
call finally made me around the back of
ten minutes but I can't get in I don't
give a [ __ ] don't mind emergency and I
would tell coach coach I got to go to
bed I shake up these hand things or I
did there's a fighter I won't say his
name there we had the same manager I
won't say his name not that famous of
fire but fighter who before a fight went
I don't want do this and the coach was
like what the [ __ ] you Tommy you have to
do this and he goes no I'm good cut my
[ __ ] raps off they went you have to
you signed up for this you have to do
this you want I don't want to do this
they talked him into it he goes out
there you know kind of just half-assed
it and then got hit with the body and
left but they were telling Mike if you
don't go out there you're you're ruined
for the rest of your life your
reputation you have kids you should be
that [ __ ] who didn't go out there man
but that goes to everyone's I don't give
a [ __ ] who you are unless you're John
Jones whose justice asen or maybe Khan
or someone or Nate Diaz or Jorge Maz
well but no it has to be rare there's
always gotta be a hero fear but I don't
think anyone on go because what I would
do is when we're in the bus driving
there and you're trafficking you know I
found New York in New Jersey I thought
Anaheim and we go by these people I just
stare out and think of everything I'd
rather be doing I watched someone walk
down the street like go I would give any
amount of money to be that person Rock
right now not have to [ __ ] do this
well it blows my mind a lot of Fighters
talking about taking naps in the locker
room before their fight did you get
drowsy because that the adrenaline saw
me to walk a secret
Joey Diaz secret here we go I do a
four-shot espresso before I go to
accomplish
four shots you've expressed oh yeah but
that isn't that a little bit different
than then you're about to go fight like
I would think though Wow fear is fear
you heard the story when I had to follow
Megan Mooney Megan the cute girl goes to
the copy store the writer from Bisbee
yeah got an anxiety attack
I want to polish you did oh my god when
was this Joey months ago Wow get to the
car I love you in this you don't little
run up the [ __ ] original room stairs
yeah I can do that 20 times even though
I'm a FAFSA one day I'm in the back
Joey you're next okay I could walk hey
how you doing eight it's a tense I'm Lee
stepped from the kitchen to the [ __ ]
original room daddy yeah 7:57 and I walk
up those steps when I got to the tax
that's my lungs closed I couldn't
breathe I'm watching Megamall he killed
I'm like [ __ ] I'm not good enough what
if I bombed the [ __ ] Comedy Store and
I just started going off and I started
breathing so I had a look around and I
saw the light coming from the outside by
the door and I looked and I could tell
that the stairway
that's what saved me this family so
Pauly's back there so go Paulie Paulie I
have to go up there right now
something's happening I'm getting like
heart attack or anxiety and he goes what
are you talking about bird I go Paulie
go up there because I already went up I
go you're the only one that's in I'm
about to have a [ __ ] on it's hair and
I went up there and I blacked out pretty
much for 12 minutes have you have this
happen before Joey never what the [ __ ]
and when I came out of it I was up on
stage it looked like Las Vegas there
were bodies everywhere one of the best
sets I've ever had a fight I see man and
what were you conscious of it was no no
no I don't know about the light came on
interesting I looked at them and they
looked at me and they clapped like oh
thank you for coming out but come up to
the stage with such and such and when I
walked off all he sure looked in English
you should have anxiety sets exact funny
things more often that when I was wrong
and the next day I'd told him the truth
piglet has the first time I
the anxiety bar yeah wow that's almost
look doctor I got the pills thing what I
didn't realize I keep them in my drug
just in case you get one have you ever
had one do it like see that's the first
time you've never had them before your
shows
I had him lightly but nothing crazy for
that extent the only time in close that
Joe and I haven't been close to that but
on a Tuesday night Tuesday and I had a
spot in the belly room spot in the main
room but spot in the belly room was 8:30
which it was just new material night
that's whatever and then had spot in the
main room but not till 10:30 so I'm
watching the other comics Tony Rock went
on just absolutely crushed and
Sebastian's neck and they destroyed okay
so he goes Tony Rock Sebastian that's
supposed to be theater close it out I'm
watching the show and Tony's just
killing I'm having such a good time and
then Sam and uh someone else from
comstor come to go hey Callen cancelled
and seals running late we need you to go
on after Sebastian we did we do three
sets tonight and what you know we need
you go on we have no one to go after
Sebastian the show's run short so we
need you to we need to extend it when
you do 15 minutes no yeah no in hello oh
yeah no problem but it sounded like oh
[ __ ] Sebastian man Sebastian I gotta
follow that [ __ ] thing dude and
then I cannot go right I go that we
might do my head I'm obviously be talks
about your hand or sweating uh it's
tough to me make me real no my hands
were sweating ah space in the back
that's the closer I've get I could feel
my breathing was hindered and that was
the first time I was like oh I'm on my
porch a little bit of anxiety right now
for a little bit of things oh I get it
all the time
first night that's why I like going in
Thursday some times to cities so I get
the big chunk of inside again on
Thursday my anxiety at the Comedy Store
the reason something yesterday that you
can so much at the Comedy Store I go I
force myself to go down there more for
the anxiety beat just to deal with it
yeah so what I started doing you know a
dial after when I was a kid I had a
coach that trained
he was such a good strength conditioning
coach in 84 you can look him up his name
is IRA or he went to the Olympics as a
trainer strength conditioning touch and
throughout my high school he never
believed and waits to where other people
did he always believed in a 10 count on
the way down you didn't do five sets of
six bench presses with him you let's say
you max 360 he would give you 300 and
just do at 10 set 20 seconds to uh up
and down I thought that's so hard and
just do them until you may have one that
says someone uh so no isolation
exercises it's rolling squatting dead
lifting bench pressing I bet he's jacked
and then he would get jacked the highest
lips he gets Jack for six months who
later I found that he didn't win TV for
recuperation
but Emily would do is he would trade it
for a marathon so he would run 26 miles
to take the muscle waffle so this is
what he did every damn to redeem and now
you gotta see him at 75 look at it look
like you think it couldn't be IRA
Murchison even though his name is IRA
wolf okay are a WOL ever okay IRA
Murchison no kept up wasn't didn't pop
up so uh I know a coach that does that
style so first stream on Cedars a we
want you to get four so I've been doing
it for a year no steady twice and what
you're doing it twice a week I go to two
different places because they give you
two different flavors so I go to the
squat machine would give me [ __ ]
anxiety like you never had before off
for sure but I put 400 on those racks
and I got to do 10 seconds up and down
big boy and they open up with it because
if you know anything about lifting you
should open up with the squat because it
opens everything up for launches all
your team all the testosterone all the
little the human just all you can hear
me feel the war
take over your body but you gotta open
up with a heavy squad couple stretches
throw some punches and go into it and by
the fourth one it would just be flying
the fight response
well that's called yeah you really like
I would you Jitsu I'm not gonna judge it
too you know I go to get you to get on
the bottom sure
so somebody get on top of me so I don't
panic yeah this is what I had to do to
make my stand up better because of my
panic attack like especially when I went
back to the store so wait a second
I gotta go behind the Liza [ __ ] the
Cyndi whoo
Ali one I gotta follow Chris D'Elia
he'll Sebastian must be yo Rogen run
white then I gotta go up [ __ ] you
that was a different level of anxiety
and you know that Rogen sits back there
and watches you you know as I am Joey we
all sit back I don't need that [ __ ] so I
stitch it so crazy that Gibby gets
because you're the guy no one wants to
follow you have no idea so I'm in the
back of my mind when I go to the store I
don't even put the radio on the drive
down there's no radio one on my drive ya
mean have you call me no can you give me
a ride to the store I'd like to but I'd
rather not like him out give a ride to
the store because I could talk to him
about what I'm going through
well most people you know linnaeus Lee
yeah and he you know I I and honestly I
used to go to the store with him a lot
more reason in the last year to I don't
really go down with him oh yeah I think
I'm seriously high level high level so I
had to attack it I had to attack the
fight-or-flight response
the other thing I do to tackle my flight
and fire response
cryotherapy that's the best thing you
don't want to freak out but you do want
the head stop no I go into the [ __ ]
closet
yeah that's the move first 30 seconds
you have to feel you get forced to
breathe how you should post it if you
don't breathe are you supposed to you
fly that thing
trouble it's cold but the only way to it
how often I do the Nova Thor bed once a
week and I do the cryo twice a week
damn Johnny I go it's right down the
corners right down the block from the
weed store so I go to the weed still
first they take a little CBD water
yes sir I go over to cry all the cryo
burns 800 calories yeah for three
minutes
you cannot [ __ ] you know and you feel
like a new man you know any time don't
knowbut or bet i only do on the Lord's
Day on Sunday because it makes me sleep
good on Sunday night but the thing you
know and I've taken people to that
cryotherapy and they've run out of it
I see people running on it I saw two
lesbians last week they were all happy
it's a beast yeah but you're breathing
it there's nothing better for you lost
your breathing and getting you have to
tell me how you say this man with
anxiety to kill me you have to so I had
to do all these things to tackle my
anxiety for stand up if I want to take
it to a level where I want them you're
at that level thought Joe that like if
you if you out imagine if you gave all
the regulars of chemist or you give him
a list said who do who's the most
scariest person to follow you're in the
top three easily because of the an
easily because he is the secret you're
like a [ __ ] the energy Cuban tidal
wave the energy concept of it I am
suffering so much inside and I have so
much anxiety inside I got two of you
unleash it I tell you the coop tango so
how does my comedy come out like a farm
yellow if I take that mic I got a
[ __ ] I'm gonna sucker there's no
measuring with no you sock him right in
the mountain you know I got I got I'm at
The Comedy Store I'm following a beast
and I got three bees behind me I told
him the adaptable economies thought it'd
be the best comic I got economy started
be remembered very difference preach
because I'm giving you a sample you only
do the comic store I don't see you at
the improv effect you know because I
only do I only go to Winkle John Smith
well I only go to Jackson Smith and if I
leave Jackson slick on one AT&T and I'm
not gonna go anywhere else from now on
after I did mine that flick special I
realized that I was going in too many
places that weren't drawing me out of me
what do you mean Johnny
one drawing who Joey beers is I want to
go to a place that Brendan Schaub comes
out the Brendan Schaub wants to go up
there and talk about masturbation and
not feel like Brendan Schaub I wanted to
have that freedom the Commish Dorset's
it's home for me right in your house
your jerk off on you when your wife says
you feel attractive oh no you you just I
wanna anywhere the Comedy Store is where
I am myself she what she preached was
yourself to come out when you come here
oh hey be yourself and you don't feel
that at the improv and laugh actor
anywhere else I love The Improv The
Improv made me who I am I started a
dirty show at The Improv laughs that's
is that where you started Joey's an
improv well no no I'm a comedy store guy
but now I know God put me on the map he
gave me a show monthly that's your next
thing like what you're doing at The
Comedy Store yeah start doing this show
monthly and if you get bored and you
don't want to come to the comest are you
close to her vine call ever I think I
want to do the [ __ ] sting and King on
Wednesday night by myself and bring Joey
and we and Brian and give them all 200
and you keep the rest or whatever and so
I had it just about why you only go to
lists yeah cuz it's hard go to the
comedy store because let's let's take
this back to an art let's take it back
to MMA so everybody understands where
I'm coming from metal sharp in his metal
I don't want to spar I'm not putting any
money down here I don't want to spar
against Dennis Seaver I want to spar
against I'm regret you want Jon Jones
come on Jon Jon Jon Jones every night
ever you want a Jon Jones guest I don't
believe Fabio Jon Jones beat me up every
day cuz I know in one year you're gonna
get that I'm gonna get a punch it up
yeah well you have no option but to get
better I know one day at the gate at the
gate before he close that elbow I'm
gonna get him with an uppercut and
that's where it started you have no
option that's for your confidence so now
the only I've got the next goal I'm
gonna have is I'm gonna get him on an
uppercut and slip out of that day and
get back to Friday in the middle so I'm
gonna take him back to the middle so I'm
not in against my back so with the
Comedy Store
Mitsy trained me to be a certain type of
sniper she trained me to be a killer
Mitzi sure trained you to be a killer
yeah richard pryor killers have come on
she wants to kenderson's Basilan else in
there was a time she wouldn't let rogue
on the mainland oh I know she didn't
wanted to do a joke in the mansion past
JSON so it would destroy it would
destroy them Joe Rogan's and the coalbed
would destroy three comics make three
comics couldn't follow um the audience
got ruffled so she would only put Joe in
the original she wants killers and I
always want to perform like I'm
performing in the original I'll do the
shows to Sam and I'll do your shows and
I really enjoy the main room because
I've gotten better over the years the
main but don't argue well my about the
belly room
you [ __ ] explode that place I like it
also but guess what a larger [ __ ] I want
to be a Jack Jackson wink yeah that's it
I got great friends at AT&T I've got
great friends and Milwaukee yeah with
the Rufus Rufus I've got great great
friends a K a KA I love the ice house I
saw say K Y K doesn't have the possess
they used anymore thank God those guys
got older up there now there could be
BAC but not all beat could be but the
only really one but all I'm always he's
got his jaw broken no crap back to LA we
shot there anymore anyway Ralph Lauren
he's you know he's that he's that uh
whatever the guy in Florida Miami
Florida but I well I got high and I shot
my Netflix special I was so upset with
myself
why because I wasn't training properly
when I now how do i when I fight you
let's be honest here let me just door
one fight out when you fought Nogueira
yeah then you woke up and you were
sitting on the mat you put your hand up
and you look around the doctor comes
over and ask you are you okay are you
thinking about [ __ ]
are you thinking about what happened who
are you thinking about where you went
wrong where I went wrong okay
I'm percent and it goes back to how many
times have we told me to cover my
[ __ ] when I threw right hand how many
time they told me that a man like one
big thing right here when I throw that
little jab
double it up but for some reason I
doubled up know it that he went this way
and I went to chase them and I put my
hand down and he caught me with that
[ __ ] left of his but you know but you
know that but when you're on the floor
you're not thinking about the money
you're not thinking about your [ __ ]
wine nothing with your kid you're
thinking about what went wrong
how's this relate to your semesters
Jeremy talk to me how is it related to
my special yeah I [ __ ] train for my
special instead of going to the store
and following Whitney Cummings and
allies and Ali Wong I decided to go to
the other rooms because I figured that
the people who like me are gonna go to
the comic store they gonna laugh at
whatever I have to say so I can't really
judge my material from that this is this
is how fear works fear works and
mysterious ways fear will talk you out
of [ __ ] if I matter if you wet and I let
it and I let it at the 26 year mark
that's that's what's crazy
so who the [ __ ] do you think you are at
the 10 year mark with Tommy at the 26
year mark of calamity I realized how
much I let fear talk me out of my game
on that [ __ ] flight that Southwest
from El from Vegas to LAX if I could
open the door and jumped out without a
parachute I would've I mean if I was
flying Southwest because I [ __ ] up I
knew where I did the things wrong I
didn't jump enough rope
I didn't shadowbox instead of going to
Eddie used to do jujitsu I went and
worked the gear up at this place and a
bunch of blue belts but why my joy
because it was just I was just fear I
was I was scared than if I would go down
to the store would have to follow Rogan
and then I would be off or you know when
I got to the store I could not follow
daliyah he was unfollow and every time I
went down an AFOL believe it wasn't as
scared as I was when I was to have to
follow Dahmer era up all morning
but it was real scary so I had a I can't
change my material or daliyah so I got a
flow flow off his energy do you hit me
Joey you have to be Joey but Chris holy
is energy and then turn into Joey so I
have to go like if you're
if you follow I lived on a dead-end
street
it had no fire hydrants if he kills it
that type of material I'm gonna go up
there and become him for 30 seconds I'm
gonna ride on his energy
Charlie go Dan keep it low also I don't
let's keep it going one more time for
Brendan sure
some guy called me a [ __ ] yesterday let
me tell you what then you know and then
you go but the first dirty I want them
to feel like nothing changed when
Brendan destroys the room where there's
bodies everywhere and I go on stage like
let's keep it going for Brendan even a
great job you just lost yeah
you just lost go Brad Brendan go [ __ ]
yourself take the train to LAX you know
I'm saying you got to go up there like
[ __ ] Brendan yeah no friend he's my
brother but that you mentality did that
[ __ ] mentality is I got away from that I
thought it became a [ __ ] how jolly bad
you've been doing this so long I got
scared I got a daughter I got mouths to
feed and I did you know you got Justin
you got your ancients you got your
managers you have all this and I'm not
gonna say the word pressure cuz I don't
fault the pressure you have you're
thinking about the other people in your
life you're doing stuff for them instead
of being a stand-up [ __ ] it's you a
microphone and a brick wall that's it
you ever seen people who do speeches and
you got eight movies behind them they
got eight white dudes a black guy a
Mexican I don't ever want to stand
behind a president of a politician you
ever see those as yes there was a fire
today in Calabasas
yeah there's eight white guys behind the
token black yeah that's the only existed
in our world so I was putting myself in
this fear and I'm not bad now for
anybody but I was going to flappers I
was going to the haha I was going to the
Improv and I was adjusting to that style
of the room I had a guest here last
night we came over in a slow Shabbat
she's a dear friend of mine I explained
to her she goes what happened she comic
yeah I told her I said this is what
happened to me I would go little
flappers and I started making me clothes
they were putting me in front of we I
can't go what do I get
what do I gain by going up there blowing
up
flappity depression Lee's been waiting
three months for this spot did that's
you like me like okay a girl that
brought everybody for work no no you
know go to jail without it going up
there she's not following Joey Diaz and
before I go up there she comes up to me
she's like this is the third time I've
been on stage
I have a daughter someday my daughter's
a new comedy does she need a gorilla to
go up and embarrass her in front of
everybody
so I would go up there and do material
that was before flappers
I would go - ha ha - ha ha materials you
get person I would get all our gold you
know I would go you know at the two
weeks ago was the first time I haven't
ran the like the comic spread - 21
minutes and 22 years really first time I
would you get off early you have to have
respect for other comics have to and so
I don't like that it doesn't do me any
right by me Hans falls down whoa if you
talk [ __ ] then I'm gonna go up in
scissor your [ __ ] world then I
could sizzle your world but if you know
the comedy store is my [ __ ] Jackson
way
yeah you can't that's basically it and I
wanna and anywhere I go I want to fight
how I do it Jackson wink when I go to
[Music]
Milwaukee
I got a spar with the ex-champ Eric no
Dennis pennis I got a spar with Pettis I
got Spanish Pettis by a hundred pounds I
got a small a little difference certain
shots right you have to be on point
because it the Comintern get knocked the
[ __ ] out I want to be you're not getting
knocked out anywhere else I'd only get
no no more so I got to go to the county
store because at the end of the day
metal sharpens metal you want to be the
best you better go get beat up every day
well yeah be a swimmer I should take you
to Otto's right now I told jujitsu I
don't know what belt you are Lal shape
you form the USC there's a blue belt
o'donnell's it's gonna tie your [ __ ] up
by the guard he's gonna put this arm
here in this arm here and and whatever
so for a year you know you have to eat
[ __ ]
you know did you listen to jazz on
account rogon three years that didn't
between specials yeah he says every
three years three years one in text or
one at the club and one year at theatres
yeah so he taught he tours Dora laughing
he does on the road they just theaters
and then when after yes theater shoots a
sweaty shooter special he's a [ __ ]
assassin now he's a guy like a shoe
especially over 18 months and get him
for a good penny he's gonna sass like
he's smart and he knows he's in here for
a long journey now were you you think
every three year are you with jazz I've
done three years I think it should be
every three years two years to shoot a
special think about it think about it
how many jokes you've done have said and
then a year later now that joke is
twenty minutes and you already used ten
minutes of it on the special you got 30
more than now are really really good
yeah you don't know where this joke is
gonna go yeah how many times have you
written a joke tried it four times
doesn't work it's not goes away but then
something happens you add to and now you
ask my for and then you've got seven so
write the [ __ ] thing down and you
know so comedy is very complex but the
Fira comedy got so much meat before the
debates you said that Johnny six years I
live on fear I'm motivated by fear I
like being scared I do my best work when
I'm - 400 that's when I do my behind
like being a favorite I've never been a
good favorite I fall apart at the seams
you make me another dog I'm a [ __ ] up
I'll figure out a way to [ __ ] you up cuz
that's what I am an underdog so I always
want to go in there - women you know we
had Jordan Belfort to me the other day
and you look through this Wikipedia
you'll see this Wikipedia underneath
this is you know everybody uh celebrity
how much you money you are network
celebrity network it says - a million
dollars pick it up show - that means
that [ __ ] gonna be doing this
work best work the rest a hundred or Sam
there's he's - what do you got to lose I
have nothing to lose but I think like
your Netflix special was a loss I don't
think it suffered I I mean yeah it was
it wasn't bad but it wasn't Joey Diaz
sorry Charlie and neither will see so
wasn't Joey Diaz that's cuz you're great
Joey and anybody who knows me from the
store that girl is that that's not Joey
Diaz it was yeah you right other person
Jesus smiles just gonna take ownership
now you have to take all the ship if you
don't you'll never grow you'll never
ever ever grow we don't take all this
[ __ ] kids could you could I mean even
Joe Rogan like his specials on Netflix
but you know he controls it all look
we'll use buying this a hundred million
so in fact I haven't paid rent in three
what let me show you this a hundred
worth he's - a hundred million dollars
that's not just faeces $56
now he's the wolf of Wall fees but wolf
of Wall Street go [ __ ]
he hell's restitution he's a hundred -
100 million okay
you can't nobody's come back from that
but he does his best worry now at - yeah
let's gonna take a while to pay off but
like with with Rogan on Netflix there's
certain guys that like a rogue in or
Chappelle where Netflix is the
distributor but Rogan control everything
he edits it you don't own it you can't
own it from Netflix but he edits it he
watch it and then sends him go this is
the final product there you go man I'm
shooting four of them I'm seeing five of
them here's the final product I had it
in mind with Netflix they're very good I
sent them notes they were very good they
accommodated me as much as possible I
just didn't like what it happens
I like Netflix I love them you know it's
a Joey see nothing mr. Joey - yeah and I
know for a fact I don't want to do an
hour I'd like to keep it in 25 minutes
my next whatever I do and I'm really no
rush right now I barely got a good 50
minutes right now say 15 or 50 50 so
before I shoot anything I want another
50 yeah I'm [ __ ] around what that's
lurk and they can chop it and you know
no I don't want to shoot the hour 50 I
want to have not seen you have to
repeting it cut the bed
two hours 225 you don't love it I'm
gonna do 50 and then add 50 ready for
you when we get rid of that 50 and I'm
already robbed I go through that [ __ ]
yes
I'm not gonna go back out there now yeah
I'm saying this ain't a joke I'm
scratchin away that's what I want to do
what I wanted to talk to you about
before I get you out of here yeah that
we you and I and Adam McCauley sort of
talent Booker yeah
have a great we'd have a great
conversation and I tell people all the
time I go I'm gonna tell you something I
don't know much about what Joe Rogan
talks about or man or moon but I know
how Comedy Works a little bit but when
my real expert T I know a little bit
about gambling and a lot of red lines
but my real expertise is if you ever get
arrested call me you had a PhD and I'll
do the whole thing for you
I'll get that I'll get you the three
attorneys will rotate them will fire one
you know whatever be involved you and I
were talking about Epstein you first of
all Adam brought up Epstein we're
talking about it and you called it - I
had to tweet out last night I saw it
[ __ ] I went holy [ __ ] - a tu in your
time I'd have to say I'm like what the
[ __ ] he gonna do it oh-hoh trying off
himself for someone to try killing
before it even gets to trial all right
now come on
billionaire sho'nuff Joey called
somebody beat him to a tee hop beat him
throw really an ex-cop that's under jail
beat him you can't commit suicide in
there cuz they got a camera in there
look there's a guy that shot the Gambino
boss in the jail in New Jersey 20 years
ago and they would have brought him out
of a body bag but now they have they put
you in a cell with a camera so nothing's
gonna happen I can only get to you on
the transfer or I could get to you on
your destination or if they want someone
to get to you right like a Whitey Bulger
situation like a whitey boat well Whitey
Bulger situation you know like that but
there's no cameras yeah there's got to
be no cameras so don't wait for you to
get to the destination
don't sit tight like the Gambino's right
now they're like we can't do them why
would we ain't worth the wait yeah wait
till we get it because there's always
somebody trying to make a name in there
you know if I know Brendan's in Attica
and I know the rat that rather I'm
Brendan even if I don't know Brendan I'm
gonna stab this mother [ __ ] gonna note
to Brent on a pencil yo yeah I'm over
here a Nord way and I got your back dog
so you get out don't forget who did this
[ __ ] yeah and I don't even take the hate
to your charge in prison I'm already
there they can just kind of hand it to
my sentence they're not gonna give so
with that with app seen someone's got a
hold of them just beat the [ __ ] out of
something supposedly somebody beat him
first slice to four punches and they got
broken up and then they put him in a
jail cell
they found him unconscious and he try
but the problem with Epstein is he knows
who the body's ahead see when he would
have those parties he would tape he
would tape them they said a bunch of
people a bunch of people so they tried
to burn the out the other day now I
always tell people lessons on the wall
about hustling cuz I'm coming at you as
a thief now yes
if you want somebody to find something
don't put it in your safe so if I kick
running this door down one night and I
put a sound city it I know I know you
got a half a million dollars here you're
really gonna have 37 in your safe and
I'll leave you all you know but you're
gonna have half a million dollars in the
ceiling somewhere so you're gonna spot
money in different places so yeah if
he's smart and he is very smart very
smart he put a couple tapes in there of
him [ __ ] 30 year old pigs whatever
getting his dick sucked and price some
other famous people don't it too but not
really the famous people he's got those
tapes hidden he knew this day was coming
he prepared know he knows you know said
he knew with Trump getting elected that
because Trump went up against him like
in 2003 there Trump testified against
him to the FBI aired he did some at the
Trump party it's like I told Rogan what
if I go to Brendan's out from them
Randall opens up the door Tom [ __ ] on a
16 year old right it's not gonna get mad
at me please don't pull me aside after
wearing the dog listen my wife knows I
can't be you'll never come to my house
ever again you can't do that in my house
you know so uh something like that
similar happening I have a friend in New
York that's a cop
tell me the political angle I don't care
I just know one thing I saw pictures of
all those big I read an article time
where he had all those people at his
summer home why I'm the guy from the guy
that gives law advice now you call it to
a [ __ ] tea that's what's in conflict
so dead men don't tell tales
I got pee so bad Joey go ahead yeah yeah
real quick why you go pre thank you for
reminding me all right my boy Brendan's
in the Bat mobile and read a little
something to you guys just let you know
what's crack-a-lackin' the church is
sponsored by policy genius I'm welcoming
them listen like I told you the
beginning of the show part of adulthood
is having to do things you really don't
want to do all right but another part of
adulthood is learning to delegate what
you hate and why you can't delegate a
visit to the in-laws and stuff like that
you could delegate shopping for
insurance policy genius is the easy way
to shop for life insurance online in
just 2 minutes listen two minutes you
compare quotes from top insurance to
find your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and red tape no sales pressure
no hidden fees just financial protection
and peace of mind we all know how it is
to get insurance and policy genius makes
life insurance nice and easy they can
also help you find the right home
insurance auto insurance and disability
insurance where can you get that at
policy genius.com so I went on to look
at a quote for my car within seconds I
got a quote fast you just give them a
little bit of information a few clicks
later there we were comparing rates so
do me a favor
if you need life insurance but you don't
want to deal with all the legwork head
to policy genius.com again grab a pen
policy genius pol LIC why genius GE and
I us one word.com it's the easy way to
compare all the top insurers and find
the best value for you policy genius
delegate what you hate especially if you
hate getting life insurance so anyway
this is net it's pretty interesting
hearing you guys talk because even
for me and I'd love to hear Brendan talk
about you guys are talking about fear
even just doing the the mere act of
doing an hour it's a lot of [ __ ] like
like no matter special this and that
like just boiling an hour
the thing is hardly I worry about now so
that's I don't worry about fear I can't
control what do you guess time batter
we're please talking about that he's
he's fearful doing an hour you got
barely 20 hours you were able to do an
hour feel [ __ ] that's the same the
fear is going down there the fear is
what happens in between well how often
are you getting up I know I do it a lot
I do it every day but I'm I'm doing a
lot or a little shorter five-minute sets
and the longer said I did I did a couple
weeks ago I did 27 but like that's what
I'm fearful about it like I'll get I'm
not I don't get to do like those really
cool rooms a lot of times sometimes I do
but what I'm fearful about now is when
someone calls me and says we want you to
do 25 because that's like every joke
I've ever written like so to me seeing
people with someone like you who's
headlining every week doing two hours a
night you just even the fact that you
can fill that time because you have to
fill that time that like that's an
accomplished
scary to me in an accomplishment like
that's where I get nervous it's just
killing the time Anita Phil no don't
worry about the time you just go up
dance time this time tango up at the
Comedy Store I got 18 minutes I do two
jokes in the white turns blue yeah this
happened especially its new [ __ ] you
know yeah it's a real [ __ ] strong
yeah but no I don't think I think that
they'll kill him before the trial
because I've seen this ace in the pocket
who's gonna be what he's gotten those
waltz what he's got hit in somewhere the
broad the broad that was booking the
chicks for hims got a disappeared well
they say now like there's a ton of
people gonna start coming out snitching
on them there's a ton of people and like
yeah the orgies are like 14 underage
girls and [ __ ] on the island now they
got the workers snitching on them you're
like there was young girls you know
topless we're never comfortable with it
yeah it's it's so this is gonna be very
very interesting so he survived now now
they got him in real solitary with
somebody to check on him every 15
minutes it's not nothing could be done
to him you know I'm saying they tapped
all his phones
I mean this isn't the people that are
looking to get him isn't the Mafia it's
not a guy named Joey bananas it's not a
guy named it's heavy-duty people that
don't want their name yeah some real
piece of people with families and
legitimate come on to lose a lot to lose
so that's why I knew he would not make
there's no way he's not gonna write a
book now he's not gonna do nothing
nothing nothing the only one who's the
happiest [ __ ] right now is Harvey
Weinstein he's been throwing parties and
[ __ ] yeah he's been as happy as [ __ ]
and then we compared his case to Harvey
you don't even hear my re no never
Harvey planned this Jesse played them
like a fiddle he played that I was
challenged like a film because he worked
the system there's a way to work the
system Brendan and it's really weird
like people think that you need or you
need money to play the system Leigh no
you just need think you just need
something of value that they need like
well I had that locked up I don't have
any money
but I played that [ __ ] system Jack
for everything I had I [ __ ] make
contacts before I got locked in I'm a
can't I reach top the people that have
been at that prison that had been at
that prison told me everything about the
thing what guards would take money she
worked on the way he I was thinking
about a god I can't George West where I
was that that he would monitor the
laundry area and you could tell him
don't go there from 10:00 to 11:00 give
him wait 25 bucks that's it 25 50 bucks
don't go there from 10:00 to 11:00 and
he wouldn't check and we would play
cards or [ __ ] some money out did you see
that Showtime series the Dannemora
those yes yeah yes I got I heard that
they already offered me that you don't
want to do it no one the best thing he's
ever seen brother you should vote or
didn't want to do it
because you know where you shot Canada
at the Canadian border so you need to
fly into Canada and then drive three
hours now the hotel was a Moute hotel
LeGrande there's nothing out of this
prisons yeah they shot it down they shot
it at then I got amaura so when you
shoot all those little cities in New
York [ __ ] out there there are nothing
gas station nightmare they do that for a
reason so all the hotels from the shoe
or an hour so that means you already in
the car two hours you know wake out of
Florida they start yeah go to edit shot
September 14 through February third
which meant my cold [ __ ] snowing up
there
Oh in September tour return in September
twenty thirty by December you got he
done and it's [ __ ] freezing you ever
do the old but no the old bananas in
Nyack there's another town a bit done
Buffalo in the winter buffalo the
weather but they have to have a sign up
today
bananas used to have to Club banana had
have you gonna bananas yet and right
across from the Fort Lee bridge huh
going to New York bananas he all by
helium but bananas had that one and
another one and I'm totally a thousand
times this one there was just a gas
station just gassed it was a hotel and a
gas station and that was your life for
three days and that's why I didn't want
to do that Dannemora and they put you in
the basement now so even with the heat
at ninety
you'd be freezing in that hotel room no
no I didn't want to do that anymore
because the truth you want a lot of
truth yeah the truth was there was eight
thousand a week so after two taxes New
York and LA taxes what's that to
Commission how many weeks a were you
gonna be there they wanted me in there
for [ __ ] eight weeks and guess what
the dude took the road the only she only
showed them he's only got a little fire
or something oh yeah that was the role
they wanna build up the guy that asked
you for toothbrush what do you want let
me get to toothbrush let me get a comb
oh yeah yeah I would give them to you
yeah that's and that would been still
and like Justin call really Ben Stiller
wants to meet we got a son there man
now deadlocked Oh I did the whole thing
then they made the Ottoman line was that
yeah after everything to commissions and
taxes that's three to be away from my
wife there's no I did eight how is not a
chance
you got a drive to Buffy and then take
another connecting flight from Buffy the
Chicago and then come here and it just
didn't work out the numbers just what
I'll imagine if you told Ben Stiller why
couldn't do it but I get it like she's a
real artist you know no I gave them I
gave you a little Ajith like I just was
complicated but do you eat I'm sure even
if let's say you're there I guess he'd
be like I can't know there's a Madison
yeah there's a million deep you could
choose from I just it's so funny people
contact me from movies all the time the
problem is and not worth it to me no the
math doesn't add up it's not about the
money I love the projects but I got a
podcast I got a wife I got a daughter
yes dad daughter has to [ __ ] do
certain things that my wife can't do it
all from one day the terrorists yeah you
know I did it for The Sopranos for three
weeks and it was tight
it was remember I called you had a new
podcast on a day's night I had to do 20
[ __ ] things to be gone for three
weeks you just can't leave the podcast
alone give him something so when I go
away from well and then then I'll shoot
nothing here no more cuz then I'll give
him a [ __ ] tax break even Sam triply
shot a TV show New York Long Island yeah
what's up when I was in New York
sensibly was in the studio with my lovin
I was in whatever and Sam typically was
in Montauk all the way at the end Theo
was at Caroline's and me and Tripp we
made plans to meet Theo and tripley hall
mingled bro I'm two hours out of New
York cycle you didn't know that
why do you think you were ten minutes
here in Montauk he was out hunting Islip
he was all the way to [ __ ] out there cuz
now on shoes the shootings in Atlanta
Vancouver China
I can't go to Kendall I can't leave the
country for a while there they will
offer me every movie here in 2005 for a
year everything your audition for you
were shooting in Rome
and I would just not even show up like
I'm not going to Romania I would ask not
to call the production company and ask
him what they gonna shoot related scenes
he and it's from 2000-2005
everything was shot Romania I heard some
crazy stories about people going over
there the whole town's you can order
hookers the hookers are right downstairs
Oh how's the order like legolas pizza
they got a menu in your room you're the
hookers they bill your room sounds fair
I heard craziness about while shoot a
movie in Romanian what do you got going
on my brother I'm on the road been on
I'm in Nashville next week Thursday
Friday Center is Amy's one of my
favorite clubs night club great and I'm
in Portland
he'll import another great club they got
tater tots the best with [ __ ] ranch
dressing and I don't eat ranch but they
put Spicer
what's that Japanese [ __ ] sriracha
sriracha that happens and Roger
mayonnaise or something [ __ ] I
remember one day I was doing pic Caesar
and helium Portland I kept looking and a
waitress put [ __ ] potato tots down
and [ __ ] that will go into a table she
goes I'm gonna leave these here for one
second the best I gotta bring drinks to
another thing dog I start eating them
like
ubereats you know when you order who
buries them you like your pizza's fresh
and that [ __ ] little Mexicans with
eating pepperonis of your pizza for this
little fence fingers all over your
[ __ ] those little fence fingers all
over your [ __ ] sets [ __ ] that we're
all so are you so Nashville next week
Portland after that then I'm in Houston
Denver you're beautiful but when we go
to Denver I'm in Denver September
hometown and Comedy Works downtown
how does it feel to go back to Denver
for you that um I've mixed feelings yeah
it's home so I you know I went to blow
any up for tickets and it's just yeah
it's easier when it's not a home you
know like whenever I'd fight at home
there's always more pressure terrible to
attend you up for tickets you want to do
it but you can do you want to do is you
see a million people you're only there
for three days but yet your shows and
it's just it's a beat when Dallas you
only fought at home who would three
fights ago
bet against him yeah he lost because I
know it's a cosmonaut home I [ __ ] hate
hate it when I go to certain clubs
because man I can't shouldn't say this
but like I'm wanting to book got an Xbox
it's sold out it's [ __ ] sold out on
this site and my friends are still
called I know is there any way yeah is
there any tickets is there imma take
your master bow I don't want to deal
with you and you don't mind giving away
free tickets but that coin you have for
30 I know I know you're home yeah I know
and they're called and called and
calling you feel like a douchebag but
you don't because they don't know that's
what I think some fighters fighting at
home it's a lot of [ __ ] price
nightmare I don't know everyone let's
take it same-same on the road Sam don't
stand up everyone wants tickets good
prominent I'm gonna do Denver this year
October 12 and then next year I'm taking
it to mold the whole school once the you
do paintin or comes out I'm doing the
bold and theater god I'd love to do
right down down by Pearl Street once and
thrown that Boulder but maybe the Fox
the Fox is on Pearl Peter thought
something yeah that's the one I'm doing
I saw the penis then my thoughts out
there and I saw Sheryl Crow there cat
there no I so sure how big is it like
the houses it's not love to do that I
would cause this I went to see Sheryl
Crow at the boulder theater before when
she was doing the dance before the album
babe the Albert just come out all I want
to do is have some fun and she I don't
think it was the phone she did something
and she was the opening act
oh damn and the next time she came back
she came back for the Fox and she was
the [ __ ] headliner love him
where'd you grow up
Arvada Aurora Aurora you miss it now I
don't know you don't miss Colorado at
all nothing about it nothing I miss it
but I miss the old Colorado
have you one that I want Denver's a
crazy man 25,000 people move there month
I go let's remove it real estate
expenses why not thousand and this got
the highest emergency room visits in the
country from all the tourists that go
there in that hi I'm trying to hike and
[ __ ] I like and try to [ __ ] eat and
edible mind your business and you gonna
cop I'm the first time I went to Denver
I was ready to pop an edible that went
eat
I forgot I've been high out
super haunted you know the first time I
took a bong hit I fell over and broke my
hands on Aspen Colorado
damn and they kept saying don't do it no
make them out to New York City I'm
Sinatra though if you could do it say
you can do it anywhere yeah I took that
bomb you know they had ice on always a
pleasure mr. love you man thank you very
much I will be the book God has sold out
but I'll be at the Lincoln [ __ ]
Theater the night before in Washington
DC and the taxes I'm coming swinging
dick and giving out Pilates September
13th that in Dallas at the [ __ ]
majestic theatre and September 14 one of
those dates around there I'll just give
me the [ __ ] Peter and the other ones
at the a-stack thing all right and Santa
and Tony I love you guys have a great
weekend sorry we're late with the
podcast but [ __ ] you guys weren't
doing nothing with your [ __ ] world
anyway I love you guys thank you very
much of support and thank you for
supporting Brendan myself in the
[ __ ] and now for a word from
our sponsors all right I want to thank
my man Brendan Schaub I want to thank my
man
the [ __ ] but most importantly I
want to thank you guys for listening I
also want to thank Vince Aero watches
why because they're the best of the best
of the best value low price and just
craftsmanship it'll blow you away
listen a wristwatch is a personal style
statement elevate your game
we've been Saros handcrafted luxury
watches and an unbeatable price like the
one I got on the silver on white it's
beautiful I've had this for a year no
problems no nothing you understand me
they put Ben Cerro provides bold
timepieces always putting quality above
all else whether you're looking to make
a statement or add a staple piece
Vince arrow has a watch for you if you
want to change it up all the Vince arrow
watch bands are interchangeable ah then
Sara offers the best value in the
industry that's what I'm here to bring
you value with exceptional craftsmanship
then Cerro exceeds expectations and
style and quality and they got over
16,000 five-star reviews listen well
joy wouldn't had them on the show if
they were in the real deal okay they
were here for a while now they're back
and I love that they're back because I
love their watch I want I reached out to
left so do me a favor get your Vince era
watch today and I'm gonna give you a
special offer for the church family go
to Vince Aaron watch is calm right now
and at the coat Church CH you are CH at
checkout for 15% off your order and
world wide shipping is always free
that's Vince arrow watches comm use
promo code Church Vince arrow VI NC ero
watches comm promo code Church CH you
are CH and I'm gonna give you 15% off
and free shipping worldwide I want to
thank all you guys all week I want to
thank this arrow
I want to thank policy genius I wanted
things if recruit I want to thank Dollar
Shave Club
I want to thank I mean listen all you
guys are part of the family I want to
thank expressvpn I want to thank CBD
Lyon but most importantly I want to
thank the church family for always
having my back don't forget we got the
Lincoln Theater August whatever the hell
it is ninth I don't know the night
before the book got the book got a sold
out that's all you need to know Dallas
and San Antonio
I'll see you savages and September
beside that I'll see you [ __ ]
tip-top Magoo bright and early Monday
morning that's it and that's that have a
great weekend and remember if this
weekend and working for you next week is
gonna be a better week I love you uncle
Joey Diaz here stay black kick this
[ __ ] meal leaf